The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEREMY KEPNER: All
right, welcome.
Thank you so much for coming.
I'm Jeremy Kepner.
I'm a fellow at
Lincoln Laboratory.
I lead the Supercomputing
Center there,
which means I have the
privilege of working
every day with pretty
much everyone at MIT.
I think I have the
best job at MIT
because I get to help you all
pursue your research dreams.
And as a result of that,
I get an opportunity
to see what a really wide
range of folks are doing
and observe patterns between
what different folks are doing.
So with that, I'll get started.
This is meant to be some
initial motivational material,
why you should be
interested in learning
about this mathematics,
this mathematics of big data
and how it relates to machine
learning and other really
exciting topics.
It is a math course.
We will be going over
a fair amount of math.
But we really work hard to make
it very accessible to people.
So we start out with a really
elementary mathematical concept
here, probably one that
hopefully most of you
are familiar with.
It's the basic concept
of a circle, right?
And I bring that up
because many of us
know many ways to state
this mathematically, right?
It's all the points
that are equal distance
from a particular point.
There's other ways
to describe it.
But this is a basic
mathematical concept of a circle
that many of us
have grown up with.
But, of course, the
other thing we know
is that, right, this
is the big idea.
Although I can write down an
equation for circle, which
is the equation for a
perfect, ideal circle,
we know that such things don't
actually exist in nature.
There is no true perfect
circle in nature.
Even this circle that we've
drawn here, it has pixels.
If I zoomed in on it, if
I zoomed in on it enough,
it wouldn't look
like a circle at all.
It would look like
a series of blocks.
And so that approximation
process, right,
where we have a mathematical
concept of an ideal circle,
right, but we know that
there are not really--
they don't really
exist nature, but we
understand that it is
worthwhile to think
about these mathematical
ideals, manipulate them and then
take the results
of the manipulation
back into the real world.
That's a really productive
way to think about things
and, really, the basis for a
lot of what we do here at MIT.
This concept is essentially
the basis of modern
or ancient Western
thought on mathematics.
If you remember your
history courses,
this concept of ideal
shapes and ideal circles
is the foundation of
platonic mathematics
some 2,500 years ago.
And at the time, though,
that they were developing
that concept, this
idea that there
are ideal shapes out there
and that thinking about them
and manipulating them
was a more effective way
to reason about the real world,
there was a lot of skepticism.
You could imagine
2,500 years ago
someone is walking
around and saying,
I believe there are
these things called
ideal circles and ideal
squares and ideal shapes.
But they don't actually
exist in nature.
That would probably
not be well-received.
In fact, it was
not well-received.
Many of those philosophers
who were thinking about this
were very negatively received.
And, in fact, if
you want to learn
about how negative the
response was to this,
I encourage you to go and read
the Allegory of the Cave, which
is essentially the story of
these philosophers talking
about how they're
trying to bring
the light of this knowledge
to the broader world
and how they essentially
get killed because of it,
because people don't
want to see it.
So that struggle they
experienced 2,500 years ago,
it exists today.
You as people at MIT will try
and bring mathematical concepts
into environments
where people are like,
I don't see why that's relevant.
And you will experience
negative inputs.
But you should rest assured
that this is a good bet.
It's worked well for
thousands of years.
You know, it's what
I base my career on.
People ask me, well,
what's the basis of it?
Well, I'm just
betting on math here.
It's been a good tool.
So this is why we're beginning
to think this way when
we talk about big data
and machine learning.
So really looking at
the fundamentals, what
are the ideals that we need
in order to effectively reason
about the problems
that we're facing today
in the virtual world,
right, and the fact
that this mathematical concept
described the natural world so
well and also described
in the virtual world
is sometimes called the
unreasonable effectiveness
of mathematics.
You can look that up.
But people talk about math.
Why does it do such a good job
of describing so many things?
And people say, well,
they don't really know.
But it seems to be a good bit of
luck that it happens that way.
So circles, that gets
us a certain way.
But in most of the
fields that we work with,
and I would say that, in
almost any introductory course
that you take in college,
whatever the discipline is,
whether it be chemistry
or mechanical engineering
or electrical engineering
or physics or biology,
the basic fundamental
theoretical ideas
that they will
introduce to you will be
the concept of a linear model.
So there we have a
linear model, right?
And why do we like
linear models?
And again, it can be physics.
It can be as simple as F
= MA Or, in chemistry, it
can be some kind of
chemical rate equation.
Or in mechanical
engineering it can
be basic concepts of friction.
The reason we like these
basic linear models
is because we can
project, right?
I know that if that
solid line represents
what I believe
to-- you know, if I
have evidence to support
that that is correct,
then I feel pretty good about
projecting maybe where I don't
have data or into a new domain.
So linear models allow
us to do this reasoning.
And that's why in the
first few weeks of almost
any introductory course they
begin with these linear models,
because they have proven
to be so effective.
Now, there are many
non-linear phenomena that
are tremendously important, OK?
And as a person who deals
with large-scale computation,
those are a staple
of what people do.
But in order to do non-linear
calculations or reason
about things
non-linearly, it usually
requires a much more complicated
analysis and much more
computation, much more data.
And so our ability
to extrapolate
is very limited, OK?
It's very limited.
So here I am talking
about the benefits
of thinking mathematically,
talking about linearity.
What does this have to do with
big data and machine learning?
So we would like to be able to
do the same things that we've
been able to do in other
fields in this new emerging
field of big data.
And this often
deals with data that
doesn't look like the
traditional measurements we
see in science.
This can be data that has to do
with words or images, pictures
of people, other types
of things that don't feel
like the kinds of data
that we traditionally
deal with in science
and engineering.
But we know we want
to use linear models.
So how are we going to do that?
How can we take this
concept of linearity,
which has been so powerful
across so many disciplines,
and bring them to
this field that
just feels completely
different than the kinds data
that we have?
So to begin with, I need to
refresh for you what it really
means to be linear.
Before, I showed you a line
and, hence, the line, linear.
But mathematically, linearity
means something much deeper.
And so here's an equation
that you may have first seen
in elementary school.
We basically have
to two times three
plus four is equal to two times
three plus two times four.
That is called the
distributive property.
It basically says multiplication
distributes over addition.
And this is the
fundamental reason
why I would say mathematics
works in our world, right?
If this wasn't true very
early on in the earliest
days of inventing
mathematics, it would not
have been very useful, right?
To say that I have two of three
plus four of something, OK,
and then I can
change it and do it
in this other way, that's really
what makes mathematics useful.
And from a deeper perspective,
the distributive property
is basically what
makes math linear.
This is the property that,
if this property holds,
then we can reason
about a system linearly.
Now, you're very familiar
with this type of mathematics,
but there's other
types of mathematics.
So if you'll allow
me, hopefully you
will let me just replace
those multiplication symbols
and addition symbols with this
funny circle times and circle
plus.
And we'll get to why
I'm going to do that.
Because it turns
out that, while you
have done most of your careers
with traditional arithmetic
multiplication and
addition, the kind
you would do on your
calculator or have
done in elementary
school, it turns out
there's other
pairs of operations
that also obey this property,
this distributive property,
and, therefore, allow
us to potentially build
linear models of very
different types of data
using this property.
So, as I mentioned,
the classic two
are circle plus is just equal
to regular arithmetic addition,
as we show on the first
line, and circle times is
equal to regular
arithmetic multiplication.
So those are the standard ones.
And, by far, this pair,
this is the most common pair
that we use across
the world today.
But there are others.
So, for instance, I can
replace the plus operation
with max and the multiplication
operation with addition, OK?
And the above
distributive equation
will still hold, right?
That's a little confusing.
I often get confused that
multiplications is now
addition.
But this pair sometimes
referred to as max plus-- you'll
sometimes hear about it as
max plus algebra-- is actually
very important in machine
learning and neural networks.
This is actually the back end
of the rectified linear unit,
is essentially this operation.
If you didn't understand
what that meant, that's OK.
We'll get to that later.
It's very important in finance.
There are certain
finance operations
that rely on this
type of mathematics.
There are other pairs, also.
So here's one.
I can replace addition with
union and multiplication
with intersection, right?
Now, that also obeys
that linear property.
This is essentially
the pair of operations
that, anytime you make
a transaction and work
with what's called a
relational database, that's
the mathematical operation
pair that's sitting inside it.
It's why those databases work.
It allows us to reason about
queries, which are just
a series of
intersections and unions,
and then reorder
them in such a way.
In databases, this is
called query planning.
And if that property
wasn't true,
we wouldn't be able to do that.
So this is a deep
property of that.
So we can put all different
types of pairs in here
and reason about them linearly.
And this is why that
many, many of the systems
we use today work.
And so this class is
about really exposing
that, that, really,
the mathematics that
allows us to think linearly
about data that we haven't
really thought of
as maybe obeying
some kind of linear model.
This is essentially the
critical point of this class.
So it goes beyond that, though.
So hopefully you'll allow
me to replace those numbers
with letters, right?
So that's basic algebra there.
Just for a refresher,
the previous equation,
we had A = 2, B = 3, C = 4.
But we're not limited to these
variables, or these letters,
to being just simple
scalar numbers,
in this case, real numbers
or integers or something
like that.
They can be other things, too.
So, for instance, A, B, and
C could be spreadsheets.
And that's something we'll
go over with extensively
in a class, so that
I can basically
have A, B, and C be whole
spreadsheets of data
and the linear equation
will still hold.
And, in fact, that's probably
the key concept in big data,
is the necessity to
reason about data
as whole collections and
transforming whole collections.
Going and looking at things
one element at a time
is essentially the thing that is
extremely difficult to do when
you have large amounts of data.
A, B, and C can be
database tables, right?
Those don't differ too
much from spreadsheets.
And as I talked to you
in the previous slide,
that union/intersection
pair naturally lines up
and we can reason
about whole tables
in a database using
linear properties.
They can be matrices.
I think, for those of you
who have had a linear algebra
and matrix mathematics,
that would have been
the first example, right, when
I substituted the A, B, and C
and had these linear equations.
Often, in many of
the sciences, we
think about matrix
operations and linearity
as being coupled together.
And through the duality
between matrices and graphs
and networks, we can
represent graphs and networks
through matrices.
Any time you work
with a neural network,
you're representing that
network as a matrix.
And, of course, all these
equations apply there as well
and you can reason about
those systems linearly.
So that provides a
little motivation there.
As we like to say,
enough about me,
let me tell you about my book.
So this will be the text that
will we use in the class.
We are not going to go
through the full text,
but we have printed out copies
of the first seven chapters
that we will go through.
And we will hand those out
later when you do the class.
So let me now switch
gears a little bit
and talk about how this
relates to, I think,
one of the most
wonderful breakthroughs
that we have seen, or
I've seen in my career,
and many of my colleagues
here at MIT have seen,
which is what's been going
on in machine learning,
right, which is-- it's not hype.
There's a real real there there
and it's tremendously exciting.
So let me give you a little
history, basic history
of this field.
So in a certain sense,
before 2010, machine learning
looked like this.
And then, after 2015, it
kind of looks like this.
So when people talk about
the hype in machine learning,
or AI, really deep
neural networks
are the elephant inside
the machine learning snake.
It has stormed onto the
scene in the last five years
and basically allowed us to do
things that we had almost taken
for granted were impossible.
Just the fact that you're
able to talk to computers
and they can understand you,
that we can have computers that
can see at least in a way that
approximates the way humans do,
these are really almost
technological miracles
that, for those of us
who have been working
on this field for fifty years,
we had almost literally given
up on.
And then all of a sudden
it became possible.
So let me give you a little
sense of appreciation
for this field and its roots.
So machine learning,
like any field,
is defined as a set of
techniques and problems.
When you ask what defines
a field, you ask, well,
what are the problems that they
work on that other fields don't
really work on?
And what are the techniques
they employ that really are not
really being employed by them?
So the core techniques,
as I mentioned earlier,
are these neural networks.
These are meant to crudely
approximate maybe the way
humans think about problems.
We have these circles
which are neurons.
They have connections
to other neurons.
You know, those connections
have different weights
associated with them.
As information
comes in, they get
multiplied by those weights.
They get summed together.
And if they pass certain
thresholds or criteria,
then they send a signal
on to another neuron.
And this is, to
a certain degree,
how we believe the
human brain works and is
a natural starting
point for, how could
we make computers
do similar things?
The big problems that
people have worked on
are these classic problems
in machine learning,
are language, how do we
make computers understand
human language, vision,
how do we make computers
see pictures or explain
pictures back to us the way
we would like, and strategy and
games and other types of things
like that.
So how do we get them
to solve problems?
This is not new.
These core concepts trace
back to the earliest days
of the field.
In fact, these four
figures here, each one
is taken from a paper
that was presented
at the very first
machine learning
conference in the mid-1950s.
So there was a machine learning
It was in Los Angeles.
It had four papers presented.
These were the four papers.
And I will say
that three of them
were done by folks at MIT
Lincoln Laboratory, which
is where I work.
And so that was basically
the neural networks
of language and vision.
And we didn't play
games, so that was it.
And you might say,
well, why is it?
Why was there so
much work going on
in Lincoln Laboratory
in the mid-1950s
that they would want to
pioneer in these directions?
At that time, people were
first building computers
and computers were
very special purpose.
So different organizations
around the world
were building computers
to do different things.
Some were doing them to simulate
complex fluid dynamics systems,
think about designing
ships or other types
of things like
that or airplanes.
Others were doing them to,
say, like what Alan Turing was
doing, break codes.
And our task was
to help people who
were watching radar scopes
make decisions, right?
How could computers enable
humans to watch more sensors
and see where they're going?
How could we do that?
So at Lincoln Laboratory, we
were building special purpose
computers to do this.
And we built the
first large computer
with reliable, fast memory.
This system had 4,096 bytes
of memory, which, at the time,
people thought was too much.
What could you possibly
do with 4,096 numbers?
The human brain, of course!
Right, that's enough, right?
Most of us can remember five,
six, seven digits, right?
So a computer that can
remember 4,096 numbers
should be able to do things
like language and vision
and strategy.
So why not?
So they went out
and they started
working on these problems, OK?
But Lincoln Laboratory, being
an applied research laboratory,
we are required to get answers
to our sponsors in a few years'
time frame.
If problems are going to
take longer than that,
then they really are the
purview of the basic research
community, universities.
And it became
apparent pretty early
on that this problem was
going to be more difficult.
It was not going to
be solved right away.
So we did what we often
do, is we partnered.
We found some bright young
people at MIT, people
just like yourselves.
In this case, we found a young
professor named Marvin Minsky.
And we said, why don't you go
and get some of your friends
together and create
a meeting where
you can lay out what the
fundamental challenges are
of this field?
And then we will figure out how
to get that funded so that you
can go and do that research.
And that was the famous
Dartmouth AI conference
which kicked off the field.
And the person leading this
group, Oliver Selfridge
at Lincoln Laboratory, basically
arranged for that conference
to happen and then subsequently
arranged for what would
became the MIT AI Lab that was
founded by Professor Minsky.
And likewise,
Professor Selfridge
also realized that we would
need more computing power.
So he left Lincoln
Laboratory and formed
what was called Project MAC,
which became the Laboratory
for Computer Science.
And then those two entities
later merged 30 years later
to become CSAIL.
So that was the initial thing.
Now, it was pretty clear that,
when this problem was handed
off to the basic
research community,
there was a feeling that
these problems would
be solved in about a decade.
So we were really
thinking by the mid-1960s
is when these problems
would be really solved.
So it's like giving someone
an assignment, right?
You all are given
assignments by professors
and they give you
a week to do it.
But it took a little longer.
In this case, it took five weeks
or, in this case, five decades
to solve this problem.
But we have.
We have now really,
using those techniques,
made tremendous progress
on those problems.
But we don't know why it works.
So we made this
tremendous progress
but we don't really
understand why this works.
So let me show you a little
bit what we have learned,
and this course will explore
the deeper mathematics
to help us gain insight.
We still don't
know why it works.
At least we can
lay the foundations
and maybe you can figure it out.
So here I am, fifty
years later, a person
from Lincoln Laboratory
saying, "All right.
Question one has been answered.
Here's question two."
Ha.
Why does this work and
hopefully you can begin,
be the generation
figured it out.
Hopefully it'll take
less than fifty years.
Historically this type
once we know how it works,
it usually takes about twenty
years to figure out why.
So I mean impasses
but maybe maybe you
know some people are smarter and
they'll figure it out faster.
So this is what a neural
network looks like.
On the left you have your input,
in this case, a vector, y zero.
It's just these dots
that are called features.
What is a feature?
Anything can be a feature.
That is the power
of neural networks,
is they don't require you
to a priori state what
the inputs can be.
They can be anything.
People have said,
well, you know,
neural networks,
machine learning,
it's just curve fitting.
Yeah, but it's curve fitting
without domain knowledge.
Because domain knowledge
is so costly and expensive
to create that having a
general system that can do this
is really what's so powerful.
So the inputs: we
have a input feature.
It could be a vector,
which we call y sub zero.
And that can just be an image,
right, the canonical thing
being an image of a cat, right?
And that can just be
the pixels, values just
rolled out into a vector,
and they will be the inputs.
And then we have a
series of layers.
These are called hidden layers.
The circles are often
referred to as neurons, OK?
And each line
connecting each dot
has a value associated
with it, a weight.
And the strength
of the connection
between any two neurons
is given by that weight.
And then, ultimately,
the output, in this case,
the output classification,
the series of blue dots there,
are the different
possible categories.
So if I put in a cat picture,
one of those dots would be cat,
maybe one would be dog, maybe
one would be apple or orange,
whatever I desired.
And the whole idea is that,
if I put in a picture of a cat
and I set all these
values correctly,
then the dot
corresponding to cat
will end up with the
highest score, right?
And then I mentioned earlier
that each one of these neurons
collects inputs.
And if it's above a
certain threshold,
it then chooses to pass on
information to the next.
And that's where these b
values, which are vectors,
are just the
thresholds associated
with each one of those.
It's a vector, one value
associated with each one
of those that does those.
This entire system can
be represented relatively
simply with one
equation, which is
that yi plus one, which is
the next vector in the layer,
OK, can be computed by
the previous vector, yi
matrix multiplied
by the weight, W.
So whenever you
see transformations
from one set of neurons to the
next layer, you should think,
oh, I have a matrix that
represents all those weights
and I'm going to multiply it by
the vector to get the next one.
Then we apply these
thresholds, all right?
So we add these,
the bi's, and then
we have a function that
we pass it through.
Typically, this h function
has been given the name
rectified linear unit.
It's much simpler than that.
It's just, if the value is
greater than what comes out
of this matrix multiplied,
if the value is greater
than zero, don't touch it.
Just let it pass through.
If it's less than zero,
make it zero, right?
You know, it's a
pretty complicated name
for a very simple function.
That's actually critical.
If you didn't have
that h function,
this nonlinear
function there, then we
could roll up all
of these together
and we would just have one
big matrix equation, right?
So that's really considered a
pretty important part of it.
So that's pretty
much what's going on.
When you want to know what the
big deal is of neural networks,
that's all that's going on.
It's just that equation.
The challenge is we don't know
what the W's and the b's are.
And we don't know how many
layers there should be.
And we don't know how
many neurons there
should be in each layer.
And although the features
can be arbitrary,
picking the right
ones do matter.
And picking the right
categories do matter.
So when people talk about,
I do machine learning
or I'm off working
on-- they're basically
playing with all
of these parameters
to try and find
the ones that will
work best for their problem.
And there's a lot
of trial and error.
And you'll hear
about there's now
systems that try and use
machine learning to do
that process automatically.
You know, how do you
make machines that learn
how to do machine learning?
The basic approach is a
trial and error approach.
I take a whole bunch
of pictures of cats
that I now have cats in them,
OK, and other things, right?
And I randomly set all those
weights and thresholds.
And I put in the vector
and I see what the system--
I guess what I think the
number of layers and neurons
and all that should be and
I run it through the system
and I get an estimate
or a calculation
for what I think these
final values should be
and I compare it with the truth.
That is, I just
basically subtract it.
And then I use those corrections
to very carefully adjust
the weights.
Basically, with the
last weights first, I
do what's called back propagate
these little changes to try
and make a better guess on
what these weights should be.
So if you hear the
term back propagation,
that's that process of
taking those differences
and using them to adjust
these weights by about
0.01% at a time.
And then we just do
this over and over
again until eventually
we get a set of weights
that we think does the problem
well enough for our purpose.
So that's called back
propagation, all right?
Once we have the set
of weights and we
have a new picture that
we want to know what
it is, we drop it in
there and it tells us
it's a cat or a dog or whatever.
That forward step
is called inference.
These are two words
you'll hear frequently
in machine learning, back
propagation and inference.
And that's all there is to it.
There's really
nothing else to that.
If you can understand
this equation,
you'll be way ahead of most
people in machine learning,
you know?
You know, there's
lots of people who
understand about all the
software and the packages
and the data.
All of them are just doing that.
And I'd say this is one
of the most powerful ways
to be ahead in your field,
is to actually understand
the mathematical principles.
Because then the software
and what it's doing
is much clearer.
And other people
who don't understand
these mathematical principles,
they're really guessing.
They're like, oh,
well, I do this
and I throw this module in.
They don't really know
that all it's doing
is making adjustments to
these various equations,
how many different layers
there are and stuff like that.
Now, why is this important?
You're like, well,
what does it matter?
As I said before,
we have this system.
It works but we don't know why.
Well, why is it
important to know why?
Well, there's two reasons.
One is that, if we want
to be able to apply
this incredible innovation to
other domains-- so many of you
probably want to do that.
Many of you want to say,
how can I apply machine
learning to something else
other than language or vision
or some of these other
standard problems?
I kind of need some
theory to know.
Like, OK, if I have a problem
that's like this one over here
and I changed it in
this way, there's
a good chance it'll work.
There's some basis for why I'm
going to try something, right?
Right now there's a
lot of trial and error.
It's like, well, it's an idea.
But if you can have
some math that says,
you know, I think that
will probably work,
that really is a great way
to guide your reasoning
and guide your efforts.
Another reason is
that-- so here's
a picture of a very
cute poodle, right?
And the machine learning
system correctly
identifies it as poodle.
One thing we realized
is that the way you
and I see that picture is
actually very, very different
than the way the neural network
sees that picture, all right?
And, in fact, I can make
changes to that picture that
are imperceptible to you
or me but will completely
change how the
neural network-- that
is, given our neural network,
I can basically make it
think anything, right?
And so, for instance,
this is a famous paper.
And they got the system
to think that that
was an ostrich, right?
And you can basically show
this for anything, right?
So what's called robust AI,
or robust machine learning,
machine learning that
can't be tricked,
is going to become more
and more important.
And again, having a deeper
understanding of the theory
is very, very critical of that.
So how are we going to do this?
What's the main concept
that we are going
to go through in this class?
This has mostly
been motivational.
But how are we going to
understand the data at a deeper
level?
You know, what's the big idea?
And the big idea is
captured now in this,
I apologize for this
eye chart slide,
which is what we call
declarative mathematically
rigorous data.
So we have this
mathematical concept
called an associative array.
And it's corresponding algebra
that basically encompasses
the data you would put
in databases, the data
that you would put in
graphs, the data that
would put in matrices and it
makes it all a linear system.
And the key operations are
outlined there at the bottom.
If you recall, we have
our basic little addition
and multiplication.
And then what's going
to be very important,
probably the real
workhorse for this-- and i
didn't show it before--
is called essentially
array multiplication or
matrix multiplication.
And that's the far
one on the right
there, which we often abbreviate
just with no symbol, just A B.
But if we really want
to explicitly call out
that its matrix multiplication
as a combination
of both multiplication
and addition,
we put in what we call the
punch-drunk emoji, which
is a plus dot times.
You're probably all young
enough that you don't even
remember emojis when
they had to type them out
with just little characters and
we didn't have icons, right?
So that meant you went to the
bar and lost to the fight,
right?
But, anyway, that's really going
to be the workhorse of what
we're doing here.